i know the opportunities that came my
way as a as a result of learning
languages hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about
how language and learning languages has
changed my life
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a review you know i
was thinking about this the other day
because here i am i'm 76 you know
and when i was 17 i spoke english
essentially
and then i got very interested in french
and so how did that change my life it
changed my life because
i was able to convert myself
into a fluent speaker of another
language i realized at the age of say 18
that that was possible
and then i ended up going to france and
so i experienced living in france
getting to know french culture
and
sort of with that i was able to travel
into spain and get a sense of spanish
and
spanish culture spanish people the
country
and then i went to china and learned or
at least to hong kong and learned
mandarin chinese
and that's a whole other world
and then i lived in japan and having
learned the chinese characters i was
able to learn japanese and lived there
for nine years and got into the culture
particularly as it applies to wood
because i was in the wood business
and all of these things and then i could
go on and on and on of course most
recently
first of all learning russian
at the age of 60 and then moving from
there into other slavic languages
discovering
so much
about those cultures and those people
and more recently my persian and arabic
again which brings those people to life
and because i learn the language i get
interested in the culture i just
finished reading a book
about an iranian lady who won the nobel
peace prize in
i think her name is uh hidabi
and so you know how has language
learning changed my life
so you know maybe i've missed out on
certain things if i hadn't learned those
languages maybe i would have learned
something else that would have brought
me great joy
so you never know about the
opportunities that you missed
but i know the opportunities that came
my way as a as a result of learning
languages
first of all opportunities say
professionally
i was able to i got my job initially
with the government because i was fluent
in french
i was
assigned to hong kong to learn mandarin
chinese by the
trade commissioner service
and um
so that was connected with my
with my work and then i worked in japan
i got a job in japan and i built my
business based on understanding the
japanese market so there's all of that
but it's much much more than that it's
it's a perspective on
different cultures as different as say
korean chinese russian
uh brazilian uh
you know greek romanian and and having
touched you know in you know very
superficially or in greater depth each
of these
cultures that make up the 20 languages
that i have either learned or dabbled in
it brings me so much
uh
perspective
um
you know
a sense of participating in
so many different ways of of looking at
our world
so
learning languages and one leads to
another
has fundamentally changed my life
whether
that was the best possible course
that i could have followed in my life
who knows you lead the life that you
lead
but uh certainly for me languages has
been an enormous uh
part of my life
and the opportunity to uh
you know start link to work on link with
my son
and develop a platform where people
learn languages we have 42 languages
there now for people to learn
and as a platform which i use to learn
and to continue learning languages and
you know here i am it's my third career
at age 76 i can't wait every day to be
able to get at
you know my arabic or my
uh persian and uh
even to get to know a little bit about
you know egyptian arabic versus
levantine arabic versus modern standard
arabic which were just
terms for me before but now that i get
into those languages i see what's what's
behind those terms and the cultures that
are behind those terms and so forth so
i just thought i'd go through that
because
you know a lot of people learn languages
for very practical reasons english is
the most popular language at least the
one that's learned by or studied by the
greatest number of people because it's
the
most important sort of international
language of communication
but uh
if you follow my channel you know that i
always encourage people to learn more
than one language
and the benefit is
not only the enjoyment of the learning
process itself
but also what you come away with even if
you end up forgetting some of the
languages that you have learned but at
least
for the time that you were learning
those languages and discovering those
languages you were entering in entering
into another world uh
a rich world that up to that point was
relatively unknown at least to me
so
just a brief ramble i was just thinking
about how lucky i was
that back seven you know
50 60 60 years ago
i
got totally wrapped up in learning
french which then led to another and yet
another and yet another and i'm very
happy that i did that so just thought i
would
share those thoughts with you thank you
for listening bye for